CNN held its second libertarian Town
Hall last night because sometimes it's
nice to hear from presidential
candidates who aren't screaming we're
decent people here's everything you need
to know we didn't even get through the
intro before this crap popped up could
they make it to the White House or will
they just play spoiler to either Clinton
or Trump those of you playing the
drinking game at home take a shot since
candidates need to be polling at least
fifteen percent to get into the debates
and there's an open on a question about
momentum fox news poll shows you a
twelve percent what do you think you
need to gain momentum this interview
right here is going to push us over
seventeen i'm sure the idea that we
should not be at those debates
expressing what's a majority point of
view in the country can only be laid at
the door of the two-party monopoly the
duopoly that has a stranglehold on power
in Washington there's no no chance of
winning without being in the
presidential debates and I based that
too on last week a projection that the
first presidential debate is going to
garner more audience than the Super Bowl
well you can't win the presidency if
you're not in that game there were a few
easy policy answers or a country of
immigrants we should be embracing
immigration we want the government out
of your pocketbook and out of your
bedroom and I think we should get out of
Afghanistan now I cut taxes 21 times he
cut taxes 14 times and the unemployment
picture greatly improved what we need to
do is d schedule marijuana as a
class-one narcotic there needs to be
research and development a few jabs at
the major party candidates and if either
trump or Clinton are elected that things
will be more polarized than ever maybe
he should consider some other line of
work like anything other than President
of the United States is there anything
that Hillary didn't promise in her
speech the other night the tax policy
center cost about mrs. Clinton proposed
tax I get at 1.1 trillion dollars and
moments that might make some
libertarians square we have to get them
into education and and just concentrate
the power of the government trying to
make sure that there are jobs available
for them it's it's a national emergency
and when there's a national emergency
the government has to respond
libertarian or no libertarian should
they be allowed not to
I think that that currently is the law
that they have to do that I don't want
to pass legislation that would allow for
that kind of dispute discrimination then
of course the inevitable happened why is
a vote for your ticket not a wasted vote
there it is everybody drink wasted vote
is voting for somebody that you don't
believe in and if you're going to
continue to vote for the lesser of two
evils that's still evil Weldon Johnson
seemed to be optimistic realists playing
for the middle and a chance to get into
a debate with two extremely unpopular
major party candidates it might be
refreshing to have a party that was not
terribly partisan holding the white
house and we would hire the best people
from the Democratic Party that we could
find the smartest people from the
Republican Party that we could find the
best people in the Libertarian Party
well that perhaps we do encompass the
best of what Republicans are supposed to
be about which is smaller government and
they don't do a very good job at that
and perhaps we're really good at civil
liberties something that Democrats
haven't stood up for mandatory
sentencing and the fact that we have the
highest incarceration rate of any
country in the world and that we
continue to militarily intervene that we
don't think you have to be all one thing
or all the other and we think we're
right in the middle because we're this
mix of these views that we talked about
this second libertarian presidential
town hall was noticeably better than
their last and after an hour or so
question and answers CNN wrapped up the
night by ah son of a-- everybody drink
you